these are the final moments before
Sergeant mattritana was killed in a
police custody Center in Croydon in
September 2020. my name is Matt I'm the
custody officer I'm in charge he was
speaking to Louis de zoyser who had just
been arrested when suddenly out of
nowhere he is shocked
the zoyser was handcuffed when it
happened with his arms behind his back
but still fired four shots before being
overwhelmed the prosecution believes the
gun was concealed under his armpit
Sergeant retana was 54 when he died an
officer for nearly 30 years he was near
retirement
his partner was in court when footage of
his death was played
dezoza also shot himself during the
incident and was left brain damaged his
arm in a sling he sat in the dock in a
wheelchair on trial for murder the jury
was shown the gun de soyuza allegedly
used in the shooting and was even
allowed to fire it inside Court a
ballistics expert explained it was safe
to use because it had been loaded with
plastic dummy cartridges members of the
jury then aimed it at the ceiling before
pulling the trigger
a place you under arrest okay the
possession of what I believe to be
bullets there's always there had been
arrested just before the shooting after
a police stop and search officers found
cannabis on him an ammunition but not
the antique revolver he was carrying in
a holster I'm just gonna have to put you
in handcuffs while I search you the
reason
what's the matter
so the reason for that is people try and
do silly things when we search them they
try and hurt themselves they're trying
to hurt police officers the 25 year old
denies murder he claims he was suffering
an autistic meltdown at the time and
that he did not mean or want to kill
Sergeant retana either Bennett Sky News
Northampton